it is an absolute lie that the police
are engaging systemic racism against
against blacks and it's not just a
harmless lie it's a dangerous lie
because what happens is the police pull
back when they're victim to these false
accusations
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster and i'm constant and
kitten and this is a show for you if you
want honest conversations with
fascinating people it does not get any
more fascinating than the guest we have
for you today he is the host of the
larry elder show larry elder welcome to
trigonometry thank you so much for
having me i appreciate it it's a great
pleasure to have you on most of our
audience will be familiar with you so we
won't get into the the details of your
life just yet uh listen the question i
i've asked glenn lowry i've asked other
prominent black people black
conservatives that we've spoken to on
the show has always been the same
question i remember where i was when
barack obama was elected i know that
you're not a fan of his
but i remember where i was because it
was a significant moment to for a
country that had had slavery for for
centuries uh to elect a black man as
president was quite a thing i thought as
just an outsider looking in what
happened larry
well i got a phone call all over the
country phone calls all over the country
after obama got elected
and i got a call from someone from from
the uk and they said
president barack obama has just gotten
elected the first african-american
president
yet you did not support him wasn't that
a bit awkward
[Laughter]
and i said for him or for
him or for me
look um
i am happy that
people feel that his election was a
statement about how fair america is i
felt america has been fair so that
america would have elected a a black
person who was qualified for a very long
period of time but for a lot of people
it was a confirmation that america has
crossed the so-called racial divide
i didn't feel that way at all again i
felt very happy that a man like that
could get elected but i didn't think he
made some deep statement about america
i'm in los angeles and in 19 i think it
was 69 la which was the third largest
city at the time
voted for a black mayor and voted for
him four times he ran twice for governor
of california the largest state in the
union uh and barely lost both times and
so i thought his statement was made a
long time ago about how fair america is
and obama just came along and benefited
from it this is a man
who has a
beautiful
resume uh came out of nowhere to be a
much more experienced politician named
hillary rodham clinton and this is
what's really important guys in 2007
there was a gallup poll and gallup is
probably the most prestigious polling
organization in america and they ask
americans uh would you not vote for a
black person referring to obama would
you not vote for a female referring to
hillary on the republican side would you
not vote for a mormon referring to mitt
romney who was competing for the
nomination would you not vote for
somebody who would be 72 years old
when he became president referring to
the aging john mccain gallup found 5 of
americans said they would not under any
circumstances vote for a black person 11
said they would not vote for a female 24
said they would not vote for a mormon
and 42 of americans in 2007 said they
would not vote for somebody who would be
72 years old when he became president so
obama had a lower hurdle a a an easier
path to the white house than these three
white politicians who were far more uh
well-funded and far more experienced and
far better known so don't give me this
crap about how obama uh somehow uh
made a statement about how fair america
is america has been fair for a very very
long period of time and he simply
benefited from the from the changing
racial attitudes uh that americans have
engaged in for decades right so that's
what i'm getting at you paint what many
people would argue is an idyllic picture
of america which is great that you do
that but what happened since what
happened since larry why is america as
we watch from the outside descending
into chaos seemingly on these issues
america descending in the chaos are you
kidding me
what about the riots what about the
burning buildings what about every time
a police officer shoots someone you know
she we just had a case we're talking
about
a girl is stabbing another girl police
officer arrives on the scene shoots the
the soul the person doing their soul and
he's now the target lebron james is
targeting him with tweets well that's
what i'm talking about okay yeah
the reaction to the allegation of
systemic racism is far more serious than
the actual presence of systemic racism
that's what's going on here let's just
take police for example you're right
about these riots that took place in our
street for four four consecutive months
a police officer an individual police
officer was accused of murdering an
individual named george floyd nothing
more nothing less but the media the
democrats uh and um and politicians have
used this to further their own interests
the media does it for ratings the
politicians do it for votes because as
long as you've been convinced
13 of the population and that's the
black population that they are oppressed
that they're persecuted by the dastardly
white man whether it's republicans
donald trump or the police they're going
to get 95 percent or so black people to
march in their like lemmings and pull
that lever for the democratic party when
you look at the numbers it paints a very
different picture there are roughly 50
million civilian police interactions in
america every year and a population of
around 350 million people that results
into 11 million arrests
60 000 officers are assaulted every year
and last year between 50 and 60 officers
were killed by civilians out of all of
that the police killed on average
according to the washington post a
thousand people per year 500 of them are
white 250 of them are black so the
police kill twice as many whites as they
kill blacks and the police kill more
unarmed whites every year than they kill
unarmed blasts it's that the media does
not care when an unarmed a white person
is killed but when an unarmed black
person is killed they act as if it's
some sort of referendum on the police in
fact out of the 7 000 homicide victims
last year black and that's 50 of the
total homicide victims in america out of
13 of the population come 50 of the
homicide victims
that's roughly 7 000 black homicide
victims last year out of that number the
number of black unarmed people killed by
cops one third
of one percent most blacks in america
are killed by other blacks just as most
whites in america when they're killed
are killed by other whites uh it is a
lie that the police are engaging in some
sort of systemic racism against black
people it has been studied for decades
there's a very long piece
in the washington post dated
specifically april 27 2016. i know that
because that's my birthday april 27
that's the 2016 part but um a long
article about the uh series of tests and
interviews with officers going back over
decades showing if anything the police
are more hesitant more reluctant to pull
the trigger on a black suspect than a
white suspect there are a group of
researchers from a university called
washington state university they've done
this experiment over decades three
different times spaced over several
years each time same result the cops are
three times more hesitant to pull the
trigger on a black suspect than a white
suspect
the number one cause of preventable
death for
young whites in america is accidents
like car accidents the number one cause
of preventable deaths for young blacks
in america is homicide a young black man
is eight to ten times more likely to be
a victim of a homicide than a young
white man that's why the cops are there
it is an absolute lie that the police
are engaging systemic racism against
against blacks and it's not just this a
harmless lie it's a dangerous lie
because what happens is the police pull
back when they're victims of these false
accusations
it's called the the ferguson effect and
now it's called the george floyd effect
where every time one of these
high-profile shootings take place and
the cops are falsely accused of engaging
in uh systemic racism the police pull
back and they just respond to radio
calls they don't they don't drive around
looking to be proactive why should they
they're going to put themselves in the
middle of something they could be
accused of of racism so they hail with
it crime goes up bad guys know it
they're out in the streets and what
happens is young black men are coached
trained to believe that the police are
out to get them so when you're pulled
over and you're a young black man
instead of it being just an ordinary
police stop it escalates into something
far more serious because you don't
believe that the officer is there to
protect and serve you believe that the
officer is an enemy so what you're doing
is training young black people not to
cooperate and therefore these incidents
escalated into something far more deadly
virtually every one of these incidents
guys whether it's eric gardner in new
york or um
michael brown in ferguson or george
floyd in minneapolis or jacob blake in
atlanta virtually every one of these
things would have been avoided had the
young black men simply comply and if
they felt that they were mistreated get
a name get a bad number and resolve it
later on instead the so-called leaders
including joe biden are throwing
gasoline on all of this by lying about
what the police are doing and making
things far far worse so the reaction to
the allegation of systemic racism
gentlemen is far far worse than the
actual presence of systemic racism
now you say that larry and you know it's
a very very good point
when we look at what happened with
george floyd that was a very very you
know shocking incident particularly for
people for for us in the uk do you think
that that is just a one-off or
unfortunately do you get bad apples in
the american police force and that this
happens every once in a while well i
think in every organization you're going
to have bad apples
maybe one percent of all police officers
are like that
the most horrific scandal in la history
is called the rampart scandal if you
remember the movie that denzel
washington starred in called training
day it was all about uh and inspired by
the so-called ram part standard which
was a big big scandal it involved a
grand total of 70 police officers
out of a police force of close to ten
thousand so it was less than one percent
now anything north of zero is too many
and a and one officer can do a great
deal of damage and damage the in the uh
the uh reputation of the other 99
and we have to deal with it but to act
as if it's some sort of of of a
broad-based uh performance on the part
of the police is extremely unfair even
in the george floyd case in the
prosecution's opening statement the
prosecutor said a black man by the way
said that the minneapolis police
department is not on trial this
particular individual officer is on
trial for allegedly murdering this
particular individual named george floyd
nothing more nothing less it's the media
it takes us
an access into some sort of referendum
on america in general and on the police
in particular when it is nothing of the
sort these things should be dealt with
on a case-by-case basis i gave a speech
once before a bunch of football students
at ohio state university i was invited
by the then coach uh and he had a black
lives matter proponent in the month
before that stirred them all up made him
all angry and he asked me if i would
come in and give my point of view and i
did and there must have been about 100
football players
and i said you can probably name the
blacks who have been killed by the
police i rattle off some of the names
and i said are you aware there are more
unarmed whites every year killed by the
police than unarmed blacks and i said
name one and i dropped my mic and i
crossed my my hands like this
and the room was silent for 20 seconds
because nobody could think of anybody i
can think of several unarmed wives
who've been killed over the years
because this is what i do but they
didn't know a single one of them i got a
phone call the other day from woman
named gloria from dallas texas
larry she's angry at me you're always
talking about uh how the police killed
unarmed whites i can't think of a time
when the police stood on a unarmed white
person and put them in the street like
that and and treated them the way they
did george floyd and i said gloria
gloria you're in dallas 2016 google a
man named tony templar t i am like mary
p like paul a he was a schizophrenic man
uh 9-1-1 was called he was put on the
ground uh held on the ground uh uh
the officer put their feet on his
shoulder he was held longer
than was george floyd it was horrific uh
the man happened to be white the
officers were mostly white uh they were
investigated but nothing happened my
point is this was in her own city and
she was unaware of it because the
national media did not make a big deal
out of it a few years ago there was a
man named kelly thomas t-h-o-m-s-a-s
his father was even a cop for crying out
loud white guy also mentally ill
not only did the police beat him up one
officer put gloves on and said i'm going
to f you up there was a big
investigation uh the officers were not
charged uh and the whole thing went away
again the national media not interested
kelly thomas was white
not long ago in california
i think was in december there was a navy
vet for crying out loud named quinto
q-u-i-n-t-o according to his family the
video and sound video the police antioch
antioch police department held his neck
for for uh five minutes
and the man ultimately died after taken
to the hospital again a big deal locally
but not a big deal nationally and the
man happened to be a filipino-american
not black ergo the national media did
not give a damn also a few months ago
police pursuing somebody on foot the
suspect runs into a backyard
police sees a man who matches the
suspect shoots and killed the suspect uh
turns out it wasn't a suspect he was the
the resident of the house who heard a
commotion came outside to find out what
was going on and the and the police shot
and killed him now the man who was shot
and killed was white the cop was white
the suspect who was pursued ultimately
captured was white ergo national media
did not give a damn had that homeowner
been a black man i'm sure we would know
his name lebron james would have tweeted
about it this is my point the police are
killing more whites every year than
blacks more unarmed whites every year
than blacks but it does not fit the
narrative it is true that the rate at
which the police kill blacks is two and
a half times higher than the rate at
which they kill whites and that's what
people often refer to but as i said
earlier a young black man is eight to
ten times more likely to be a victim of
a homicide than a young white man so if
anything the two and a half time rate is
lower than one would have predicted
based upon the number of crimes that are
being committed so if anything the
police are showing great deal of
hesitance and reluctance in pulling the
trigger against a black suspect then the
white suspect larry what about non-fatal
incidents because we had coleman hughes
on the show who i'm sure you know
a a very interesting young guy and he
was talking about the evidence that
there is some evidence to suggest that
police are more likely to rough up a
black suspect versus a white suspect
isn't that an area of concern uh no not
an area of concern
the uh harvard uh
a black harvard professor named roland
fryer f-r-y-e-r
um had never done any work on police
shootings of blacks
but because of the high profile stuff he
just knew that the police were uh using
disproportionate deadly force against
black people and thought he would do a a
survey to to prove this
and he said the results were the most
surprising of his professional career
again not only were the police not
killing blacks because they were black
the police were more hesitant or
reluctant to pull the trigger on a black
suspect than a white suspect he did find
however
that the police were 18 to 20 times more
likely to use non-deadly force on a
black suspect than a white suspect i
have two reactions to that the first is
18 is not a whole lot more but more
importantly isn't that because they
don't want to get to the point where
they're using deadly force so therefore
they're using non-non-deadly force more
frequently on the black suspect not to
get to the point where they're at defcon
one that's probably what's going on when
you talk to cops that's what they tell
you we do not want to use deadly force
on the black person that's the last
thing we want to do as a result very
likely they're using non-deadly force
probably more urgently on a black
suspect than on the white suspect if
that's what's going on i don't find that
a bad thing
and
if that is the case and why is it that
we get the president of the united
states talk about systemic racism you
get karma harris talking about systemic
racism the police are institutionally
racist or why is this happening then
it's a con
for votes regarding mr biden mr biden
has been lying about his civil rights
record for over 30 years for 30 years he
has said when i was a young teenager in
wilmington delaware i would go to black
churches and i would strategize on how
we were going to desegregate lunch
counters and movie theaters in
wilmington delaware no evidence he ever
did any of it and when the new york
times a few years ago investigated and
said just what i said the new york times
said
biden's aides quote gently reminded him
close quote that what he said is not
true and biden kept saying it anyway
said the new york times biden has lied
and said that every time he's ever run a
race the naacp has endorsed him the
naacp is the most prestigious civil
rights group in america the naacp is a
non-profit they cannot endorse anybody
they have never endorsed him he lied he
lied and said that when he was in south
africa during apartheid he was arrested
trying to visit nelson mandela in jail
no evidence he ever did any of it this
is a man who once told a black radio
host
if you don't want to vote for me uh but
if you don't know whether you want to
vote for me or vote for trump by now you
ain't really black uh this is a man joe
biden who once told a predominantly uh
black audience that his opponent who did
not want to uh to push for further
regulations on wall street wanted to
unchain wall street when an unchained
wall stick want to put y'all
back in chains this guy has played the
race card his entire career it is
insulting he treats blacks like children
to whom the truth cannot be told and i
find it i find it vulgar regarding
kamala harris exactly the same thing
pick up the race card play it stir up 13
of the population get them voting 95 for
us and it will keep us in power never
mind the damage these lies do to black
people the number one problem facing
black america is not systemic racism
it's not uh inequality it's the fact
that 70 percent 7-0
70 of black kids are raised or brought
into this world without a father in the
home and barack obama once said a kid
without a father is five times more
likely to be poor and commit crimes nine
times more likely to drop out of school
20 times more likely to end up
in jail now the question is why has
america gone from having 25 percent of
young black
black boys brought into the world
without a father 25 in 1965 to 70 right
now and i argue gentlemen it is the
welfare state the welfare state has
incentivized women to marry the
government and has and has allowed men
to abandon their financial and moral
responsibility it is particularly hit
hard in the black community but not just
the black unity 50 of hispanic kids are
raised without fathers and i mentioned
in 1965 25 of what blackheads were now
25 of white kids are all together 40 of
american kids are brought into the world
without a father married to the mother
it is far and away the biggest problem
facing this
country hey kkk are you a fan of
cultural appropriation of course i can't
go down to the local supermarket unless
i'm dressed like a mexican bandit or as
i like to think about it your cousin in
that case you're going to love beer
rebel noodles they make award-winning
delicious ramen noodles with an irish
twist for bankruptcy and alcoholism no
all their noodles are homemade using
high quality ingredients in fact
respected food critic jay raynor called
them deserving of poetry what [ __ ] man
up jay their sauces noodles and broths
are created using skills that were
developed over years of working in
michelin-starred kitchens they're dead
easy to make the noodles take one minute
to cook and the whole dish takes only 10
minutes to put together in the comfort
of your own home i'm hungry just
explaining this to you you're always
hungry mate i mean that's a fair point
go to beerble.com
that's
e b b-i-a-r-e-b-e
l dot com and get a tasty flavor of the
east in your dinner time
larry you you bring up uh that issue
which i know is a big uh it's thing you
care a lot about and it kind of ties
into your personal story which i wanted
to touch on uh your brilliant movie
uncle tom uh which i really enjoyed and
it's just so beautifully made touches on
that your many books you've talked about
this as well tell everybody sort of an
abridged version of your story your
father your family because a lot of
people watching this or
you know in the uk what you're saying
will be just they've never heard it
before you're like a unicorn a black man
talking like you are is incredible so
how did you become so strange larry how
did you get to to where you are now well
the reaction often is well this guy must
have been born on third or third base
and thought he hit a triple uh
my father cleaned toilets when i was
growing up
my father had two full-time jobs
cleaning toilets he cooked for a family
on the weekend and went to night school
to get his ged because my father was
kicked out of the home when he was 13
years old by his irresponsible mother my
last name elder is not the name of my
father's biological father it's the name
of a man who was in my dad's life the
longest who's an alcoholic was
physically abusive my father never met
his biological father my father comes
home at the age of 13 and starts
quarreling with his mom's then boyfriend
the mother's side with the fog with the
boyfriend throws my father out of the
house never to return
you're talking about a 13 year old black
boy in the jim crow south at the
beginning of the great depression and i
defy very many people listening to us to
um to find somebody who had a hand dealt
like that my father just took any job he
could ultimately he became a pullman
porter on the train they were like a
valet for the trains
and he came out to california and it was
sunny and people seemed less racist and
my father said i could walk into a
restaurant in the front door and get
served it blew his mind and he decided
maybe someday he might relocate to
california well uh the war broke out my
dad joined the marines he was stationed
in guam he was a staff sergeant in
charge of cooking my father can look at
a cake and tell you what's gonna that's
how good he is uh after the war is over
he goes back to the south a place called
chattanooga tennessee where he met
married my mom
and he walked around all day to get a
job as a cook and he was told to his
face we don't hire [ __ ] my dad went
to an unemployment office the lady said
you went to the wrong door he goes out
to the hall he sees colored only goes
through that door to the very same lady
who sent him out he came home to my to
my mom and said this is bs i'm going to
california i'm going to give me a job as
a cook he walks around out here to l.a
and he's told you don't have any
references my father said i need
references to make ham and eggs so he
goes to an unemployment office this time
just one door
and as i mentioned he takes the first
job he can get cleaning toilets for 10
years
at a bread company called nabisco then
he got another job full-time clean toys
and another bread company called barbara
and bread and then went to cook for a
family on the weekends and went to night
school to get his ged the reason my
father was always so grouchy the reason
my brothers and i disliked him so much
is he was tired all the time when i was
25 years old after not having spoken to
my dad for 10 years because i thought he
was such a mean person we sat down for
what i thought was going to be a five
minute conversation it ended up ended up
being eight hours and during the eight
hour conversation my father outlined his
life just as i did to you guys and i
wrote a book about this called dear
father dear son two lives eight hours
about this conversation
excuse me and by the time we ended the
conversation i'm crying because i judge
my dad so harshly and i said father
please forgive me and my dad said
there's nothing to forgive just follow
the advice i've always given you and
your brothers hard work wins you get out
of life what you put into it larry you
cannot control the outcome but damn it
you are 100
in control of the effort and before you
complain about how somebody mistreated
you go to the nearest mirror look at it
and say how could i have how could i
have changed the outcome and finally he
said no matter how hard you work how
good you are sooner or later bad things
will happen how you address those bad
things will tell me and your mother if
we raised a man if anybody had a right
to believe america was bedeviled by
systemic racism it is my father my
father was the most hopeful optimistic
person you ever saw in your life and he
was a lifelong republican even though my
mom was a lifelong democrat my father
used to always say democrats want to
give you something for nothing and when
you try and get something for nothing
you almost always end up getting nothing
for something that was his philosophy
and that is my philosophy
right and it's a very very powerful
philosophy larry and
why is it do you think that so many
particularly young people have fallen
for this narrative of blm and what the
democrats are saying if it isn't true as
you say uh by the way the bull on my
dad's story is my dad saving nickels and
dimes and when he was 42 years old he
started a cafe which he ran until he was
82 years old bought the property next
door bought his own house of course my
father is a success story if there ever
was one as for your question what's
going on here it's because it advances
the agenda of a whole bunch of people it
advances the agenda of al sharpton it
advances the agenda of jesse jackson it
advances the agenda of the democratic
party it advances the agenda of the
media that does it for ratings and i'm
convinced many young reporters have been
indoctrinated into this notion that
black people are bedeviled by systemic
racism you know there's a genre of movie
called this the white savior movie that
now all of a sudden uh is a negative
genre
it's movies like michelle pfeiffer she
takes a job as a teacher in the inner
city and turns around all these rough
black guys it's sean connery in a movie
called saving forrester where he
basically adopts a black kid and turns
him around all of a sudden movies like
that are considered to be patronizing
and demeaning and condescending they're
called white savior movies but white
savior politicians like joe biden who
lies about his civil records to get to
get votes uh people like uh
beto o'rourke who accuses america of
engaging in endemic racism a term i've
never heard before foundational racism a
term i'd never heard before they're not
called white savior politicians but
they're doing the very same thing
treating you like a child to whom the
truth cannot be told the idea that the
georgia voting law is voter oppression
you're saying black people can't figure
out how to vote
it's insulting but they do it for votes
and unfortunately because of the failure
of a lot of blacks they have appropriate
guidance in the home to teach them
appropriate values they're falling for
this they're angry and they're and the
democrats are tapping into this anger
and not saying the way to deal with this
anger is pick up your cards the way
larry elder's dad did and and deal them
and play them to the best of your
ability if larry elder's father can
become a success
decades ago
how in the world can you complain right
now in 2021 where all you have to do is
work hard stay focused and void avoid
bad moral mistakes and you'll be just
fine in america
do you really believe that larry or
isn't there isn't there some parts of
america that are so riven with poverty
that it's almost impossible to get out
of you know the fact that the rich and
the gap between rich and poor is
increasing all the time
1997
cnn and time magazine teamed up
to do this massive survey of black teens
and white teens in america
and both were asked do you believe that
racism remains a major problem in
america and not too surprisingly the
majority of both said yes but then time
and cnn uh asked the following question
again this is uh 1997 we're talking
about 24 years ago
is racism to the blacks a major problem
a small problem or no problem in your
own daily life
89 of black teens said racism was either
a small problem or no problem in my own
daily life in fact more black teens than
white teens said and i'm quoting failure
to take advantage of available
opportunities is a bigger problem than
racism more black teens said yes to that
proposition than did white teens all you
have to do is stay focused
but as long as every night a black child
does less homework
than a white child and substantially
less homework than an asian american
child we're always going to have this
problem which means it comes back to the
home barbara bush
the wife of the former president george
herbert walker bush said what happens in
your house is far more important than
what happens in the white house and that
was true then it is true now
larry but i guess what francis is
getting and and maybe picking up on both
your points you make the case obviously
the breakdown of the family you put that
together with growing up in a
neighborhood that's full of crime not
many jobs not many good examples not
many good role models and it does become
in that situation a lot harder to dig
yourself out of that situation than it
would be for someone else so
is it is it all just about hard work or
do you not think there is an element
where you know government can intervene
or private enterprises can intervene to
make life easier for people who do have
a harder time they've like you say
who've been dealt some really bad cards
in life
well put it like this
if there's nobody in your home to make
sure that you have gone to bed on time
there's nobody in your home to make sure
you've done your homework if there's
nobody in your home to make sure you've
gotten three squares a day and that
you've been sufficiently uh educated to
appreciate education so that you go to
school willing willing to learn there's
nothing anybody can do
and if barack obama the most respected
man in america said the kinds of things
i said and talked about the lie of
police systemic racism and talked about
the importance of hard work i don't
think we're having this conversation
and
that being the case larry we are where
we are how do we solve these problems
how do we improve society because it's
all very well to identify a problem but
we need solutions don't we
the the solution begins with changing
your perspective there are seven billion
people in the world i'm arrogant enough
to believe that the majority of them
would come to america if they could
right now there are some cubans
uh facing shark-infested waters trying
to get here to america all you have to
do is appreciate education you get a
free education k through 12. america
spends more more money k-12 than any
other country in the world other than
luxembourg and switzerland where we're
getting lousy results you have to do
your homework
there are think tanks on the left called
the brookings institution arguably the
the most prestigious think tank in
america on the left and there are think
tanks on the right one of which is the
american enterprise institute and they
both pretty much said the same thing
about how to escape poverty it's called
the millennial success sequence finish
high school don't have a kid until you
get married get a job keep a job don't
quit that job until you get another one
and avoid the criminal justice system
you do that the percentage of people who
are in poverty is single digits you
don't do that the percentage of people
who are in poverty is in double digits
close to 50
that's the formula for success you don't
follow that i don't know what to tell
you
but if somebody doesn't have somebody
at home
in order to keep them on the straight to
narrow you know i'm a former teacher
i've seen it myself time and time again
it comes a point especially in a boy's
life
where mum can't control him anymore
we're 13 14 years old he gets physically
bigger than mom he says you know what
i'm gonna go out there's nothing that
you can do to stop me right
and that's where mentors come in
and that's where programs come in and
there are lots of programs big boys big
brothers big sisters get involved there
are lots of people right now who are
retired people retiring earlier and
they're healthier and more vigorous i
urge all these people to get involved
i've been doing radio for about 30 years
guys and i've tried to get jesse jackson
on my program he won't come on maxine
waters won't come on minister farrakhan
won't come on al sharpton won't come on
but one of these so-called black leaders
i did come on his name is kawei saying
fumey at the time he was president of
the naacp before that he was a member of
the house from baltimore and now he's
back in the house from baltimore and i
said mr influence as between the
presence of white racism or the absence
of black fathers which poses a bigger
problem in the black community to his
credit without missing a beat he said
the absence of black fathers we need to
shower the community with role models
with leaders with men who've raised
their families who are now retired and
can use their knowledge and advice and
wisdom to help other people get involved
mentor people again if there's nobody in
your house to tell you to go to bed on
time and make sure you've done your
homework i have no other i have no other
other answers for you other than you've
got to do that you have to pick up your
cards and play them to the best of your
ability that is your moral duty and
anybody that tells you other other than
other than to do that is is engaging in
my opinion in a horrific disservice to
these young black people who need to
hear a positive voice and
to know and to see a positive vision
larry you talk about doing a disservice
one of the things that i find really
troubling about the times we're in and
the way that these conversations are
being had is everything has now become
about race and you know growing up i was
a huge michael jordan fan now i'm i was
born in russia uh from a sort of russian
jewish background not black clearly
right but and it never occurred to me
that michael jordan was black because he
was just a great man who i found
inspirational and i just wonder if i
have a son now who's 12 13 playing
basketball as i did as a kid i don't
think there's any possibility for him to
have that pure unadulterated experience
does it concern you that we're so
obsessed with this issue now
absolutely i i've said race is has never
been less significant a factor in
american success uh but it's never been
a more significant factor for the
democrat party's success and that's
what's going on you mentioned michael
jordan
remember the dream team in the 90s they
went around they clobbered the whole
world they won games by 50 60 70 points
they're not winning those games like
that by those by that margin anymore
because the rest of the world raised
their game we didn't lower the hoop
they raised their game
black americans need to raise their game
again as long as we're spending way less
time doing homework every night than
white kids and way less time every every
night doing homework uh than asian
american kids while being perfectly
willing to go to the gym
and practice the jump throw 500 times a
night we're in trouble
most kids are not going to become
basketball players you're going to do it
the way i did get an education go to
college get a job and work your way up
in your career that's what we ought to
be telling people but we're not
and how is that how's that message
getting through larry
well it's not getting through when you
have a shooting like this and you have
somebody like lebron james who lives in
the gated community saying quote black
people are afraid to leave their homes
close quote you're not helping anything
uh when i just now got off from watching
cnn uh and they had a um an educator on
who talked about uh the importance of
putting time into educating and he's got
a a non-profit that's only done by
donations that graduated 100 of kids
onto colleges he talks about
how hard this is and why this is
important and the two cnn host suggests
it's very good not not to hear a bunch
of negative stuff well you're the ones
putting out the negative stuff uh when
george floyd got uh got got killed that
was 24 7. meanwhile a few days ago a
two-year-old toddler shot in the head
black toddler by another black person
and kamala harris was in chicago the
following day on some sort of joe biden
infrastructure initiative she didn't
mention it nor would she even ask about
it in chicago which is a third black or
third white and the third hispanic 80
percent of the homicides black on black
kamala harris did not say one word about
that baltimore has a murder rate three
times higher than the murder wave of
chicago even though chicago has the
greatest absolute numbers of homicides
every year but chicago last year there
were 400 homicides 90 of them black on
black in a city of roughly 65 black
people st louis 45 black people 300
homicides last year 90 black on black
where's kamala harris where's joe biden
on that not a damn thing but you let a
white cop shoot a black person and
they're ready to march on washington
it's misdirection it's causing energy
and attention to be diverted away from
k-12 schools there are 13 public high
schools in baltimore where zero percent
of kids can do math at grade level and
another half a dozen or only one percent
can yet the democratic party is opposed
to vouchers so that the money can follow
the child rather than the other way
around so maybe a parent living next
door to a school where only 13 of the
kids can do math at grade level and put
that kid into a better school so the kid
can have a better possibility the
democrats are on the wrong side of that
issue and for for some reason black
people still pull that lever 95 for them
even though the number one route to
escaping poverty is a quality education
and larry i i agree with you on the
issue when it comes to education it is a
number one it's the only way for the
vast majority of kids who come from a
deprived background to get out of that
situation but why is it that we can't
have sensible discussions about this
topic we have the same problem in the uk
we recently had a race report
commissioned by a conservative
government
yeah and all of a sudden it just
descended into name calling you know all
these
people who were who were on the
commission very very notable people very
well respected people
but a lot of whom were black
conservatives had horrible epithets held
at them why can we not have a simple
honest and rational discussion about a
topic let's be fair doesn't just affect
black people it affects everyone
well the reason the left does not want
to hear this is because if what i'm
saying is true
that means the policies that the left
has been pushing for the last 50 years
giving people more and more stuff
to encourage them to marry the
government as i put it they have to
rethink that that requires them to
rethink everything they believe from a
to z and that is a discussion they don't
want to have talk about cognitive
dissonance and so therefore if you have
that philosophy
and anybody who disagrees with you is
not only wrong they become part of the
problem they become part of the enemy
that's why you can't have a rational
discussion uh i believe that the other
side is wrong the other side believes
i'm not just wrong but i am a bad human
being i'm a fundamentally bad person
when you have that kind of attitude how
in the world are you going to have a
discussion let me just give you another
example example of the intolerance of
the left
there is a black editor of the new york
times arguably the most important
newspaper in the world uh his name is
dean buckay
first black editor and he's still there
one of the one of his decisions was to
hire a new columnist named brett stevens
he's a republican a trump basher
white
uh the kind of republican the new york
times often hires the ones that will
take swipes at the republican party i'm
not a fan of brett stevens but he hired
him
and brett stephen's first column was
about his skepticism about climate
change alarmism he wasn't skeptical he
wasn't skeptical about climate change
the climate is always changing he was
skeptical about the extent to which it's
going to have all the horrific
consequences that some people claim that
was his first call
dean mckay said people contacted the new
york times complained canceled their
subscriptions and he later on publicly
said i found out quote that the left as
a general rule does not want to hear
thoughtful disagreement
quote
this is the executive editor of the new
york times saying the left as a general
rule does not want to hear
thoughtful disagreement close quote so i
argue the left is the problem they don't
want to hear thoughtful disagreement
whether it's about climate change
whether it's about uh racism whether
it's about what the welfare state has
done to the family they don't want to
hear thoughtful disagreement so i urge
my friends on the left to look into the
mirror and ask yourself do you really
want to have a conversation or do you
really want to just denounce the other
side
and you say denounce the other side why
is it so taboo for a black person to
come out as a conservative when you bear
in mind so i when i was working i used
to i spent a lot of my career working in
south and east london were with a lot of
first generation african immigrants
second or third generation caribbean
most of the people that i encountered in
those schools were socially conservative
and
conservative in their values as well so
why is it that it's taboo for a black
person to be conservative
again i represent the worst nightmare
for somebody on the left somebody who
believes in hard work somebody believes
in merit somebody who does not believe
in lowering standards somebody's not
blaming white people somebody who
recognized that the most important thing
is the family
that shoots down a whole bunch of sacred
cows on the left so i become a villain i
understand that
somebody once asked thomas soule why it
is you don't spend your time trying to
convince some of these so-called black
leaders of the wrongfulness of their
point of view he said i would never i
would not waste my time uh trying to
convince people to to drop using
victimhood
to make a living as i would to try to
convince the mafia to stop engaging in
crime
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns of
rock-solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 off with the initial
purchase sign up for their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know about technology
privacy and censorship
and do you think this is really part of
it and i it happens on the right as well
but particularly on the left it seems to
me that the the politicians like the joe
bidens and the kamala harris's and
others they're sort of held hostage by
the extremists in their base they're a
small fringe but they're very their
voices are powerful and the moment
anyone steps out of line they will come
down on you like a ton of bricks and
then they will ruin your your reputation
in the democratic party and you'll never
get elected unless you bend the knee to
this ideology
i think you're right i think the real
power in the democratic party uh is the
so-called squad people like aoc
and they are putting a lot of pressure
on people like joe biden who for the
most part uh ran as a moderate he would
even point blank was asked about the 15
minimum wage ask about reparations ask
about uh tuition for debt forgiveness
ask about whether he wants washington dc
to be a state ask about getting rid of
the filibuster he was asked specifically
about all those things at some point
during the campaign and he said he was
not in favor of them now he's probably
in favor of all of them i think he's
yielded to the power of that of that
part of the squad that's where the base
is that's where the money is
aoc even though she's barely
been in in congress for what two or
three years arguably has more power than
almost anybody in the house because of
her social media following so i believe
that the democratic party is
increasingly becoming beholden to the
far far left and ultimately that's going
to be their undoing in the midterm
elections because i believe there's a
good chance that the house will be
returned to the republicans and
eventually the the the senate will too
which will basically stall joe biden's
agenda which is why i believe they're
trying to do as much as they can in the
first two years of biden's
administration because of the chance the
real strong chance they may they may
they may lose the house come 2022.
and do you know i think as well larry
the the part of the problem with the
american system is
if you were in the middle you had trump
on one side who
deeply divisive
for a lot of people you know his
rhetoric his attitude was unpleasant
then you had the people on the left who
quite frankly seem to have gone
completely tonto
and if you you're a rational sane
reasonable person you had two dreadful
options
well i saw it a lot differently
obviously you know i i don't i don't
disagree with you about trump's
personality as temperament he's the easy
person to dislike but if you look at his
policies uh lower corporate taxes lower
individual taxes same same policy george
w bush had uh he was strong in national
defense same as george w bush basically
his policies were pretty uh standard
republican stuff although he was far
more uh protectionist and i think most
republicans are and he was tougher on
china uh than i think most republicans
expected uh but basically his point of
view is a standard public republican
point of view i urge all my friends
about donald trump uh to follow the
example i saw once when i was watching
the golf channel
there were these two professional
golfers guys and they were both asked by
the host how can you tell if a golfer's
a good golfer
and one golfer went through this
elaborate beautiful detailed description
of what makes a good golfer
the placement of his arms how he locks
his arm how he swivels his hips how he
looks at the ball and all of this stuff
he was beautiful and the other golfer
had his arms folded kind of was rolling
his eyes as the other one was speaking
and the and the post said what about you
he said i look to see where the ball
lands
i like where the ball was landing under
donald trump don't look at his swing i
didn't follow him on twitter he didn't
follow me on twitter because i thought
he tweeted too much about stuff i didn't
care about but i cared about where the
ball landed on immigration i cared about
where the ball landed on the economy on
regulations on putting conservatives on
the courts i cared about all of that
stuff and for my money he deserves an a
plus in the rate in the face of
relentless hostility 91 of the media
negative news much of his own party
negative uh and and still this guy
persevered and barely lost the election
i remember the americans didn't didn't
repudiate trump's policies they
repudiated trump personality uh the
republicans gained seats in the house
when the predictions were where they
were going to lose it they're supposed
to get waxed in the senate uh and it
held at 50 50. you look at 43 000 votes
in three states and donald trump remains
there for another four years it was a
bear with a very close loss and in my
opinion a few things here and there uh
including the
failure to
uh the way twitter suppressed that new
york uh post uh hunter biden story
around eight percent of joe biden's
voters did not said had they known about
the story they would not have voted for
joe biden that would have been enough
for for uh donald trump to have won so
just a few little things here and there
and donald trump's
back for four more years so don't assume
donald trump's defeat was a defeat of
republicanism because more republicans
control governorships uh than democrats
they control more state house than
democrats so the republican party is
alive and well in america it was donald
trump who lost not republicans a liar
and you being a black
republican how do you explain the fact
that donald trump you know for for four
years we heard about how evil racist
bigoted xenophobic he is and yet his
share of the vote of the minority
population blacks latinos etc went up
how did that happen it's called the
economy under donald trump black
unemployment reached its lowest ever on
a donald trump he pardoned the first
black heavyweight champion of america
his name was jack johnson uh who was
tried before violating what's called the
man at ie he transported a white woman
across state lines and he was persecuted
and for 15 years people like the actors
fly stone uh and uh ken burns the
documentarian have gone to uh presidents
george w bush barack obama and donald
trump asking all of them to pardon jack
johnson the only one who did it was
donald trump uh donald trump also signed
what's called the first step act
that allowed prisoners to have their
lengthy sentences weak or reconsidered
uh some years ago we put very long
sentences for drug offenses and under
the first step act again signed by
donald trump some 6 000 mostly black men
have had their sentences reconsidered
and reduced an average of around 70
months uh donald trump also put funding
for black colleges on a permanent basis
for the next 10 years first time that's
ever been done he also expanded what are
called opportunity zones so you get tax
breaks uh if you go into real estate in
the inner city and at least one nfl
player is getting rich using the very
same opportunity zones that donald trump
has put into place so for all those
reasons uh his percentage of the black
vote went up the only area major demo uh
black uh black men black women asian men
asian women hispanic men hispanic women
white women every major demo he went up
in 2020 except
white men but i thought he was sending a
dog whistle to weight to racist white
men so it's bizarre and by the way
in 2016 when he won
a prominent black pundit on cnn named
van jones called it whitelash
that the growing number of whites in
america were angry that there was a
black president and they were firing
back
to give you an idea of how cockeyed that
analysis is
the city of over 100 000 that voted most
for for donald trump in 2016 abilene
texas 80 percent of those in abilene
texas voted for donald trump guess which
city shortly after donald trump got
elected voted for its first black mayor
in 138 years abilene texas so how is it
that racist white people voted for
donald trump and then the same rights
racist white people voted for somebody
to be a mayor of their city and almost
the same percentages it's a lie
and larry
america is where it is
are you hopeful because to me it seems
and look i'm only going by what i read
in the media i only go by why i see on
twitter you know twitter is not real
life etc etc but from looking at it from
the uk it seems more divided than it
ever has it seems more angry than it's
probably the exception of the civil war
yeah
but
but it
it does feel that way is that what it's
like on the ground in america and if so
are you hopeful
yeah i i i believe that the captain of
the titanic had he known the iceberg was
there would have taken evasive action
um look all we have to do is remind
people in america of what made america
great and i think we're getting away
from that i call it the access of
indoctrination hollywood media and
academia are all indoctrinating young
people into believing that america is a
racist hellhole it's sexist it's this
it's that 61 of democrats believe all
republicans are racist slash sexist
slash bigoted according to a major major
poll that i saw
and as long as half the country believes
that a way about the other half we're
going to be having difficulty but when
you look at what's really going on in
the ground
that somebody from uh somebody from
poverty uh can make it and become very
wealthy uh in america in one generation
faster and easier than anywhere else in
all of human history that's really
what's going on on the ground barack
obama despite all the crap he says
things like racism is in america's dna
if i had a son he looked like trayvon
and all the nonsense he said uh in his
final year he gave a speech commencement
speech at a black college
and he said to these young optimistic
eager-eyed students if you could be born
anywhere at any time in history
where would it be and when would it be
and he said it would be here and now and
that is the truth the truth is things
have never been easier for somebody to
become successful in america than right
now but it's never been more important
for the democrats to convince you
otherwise than right now for their own
power so think for yourself work hard
pick up the cards play them to the best
of your ability and follow that
millennia uh success sequence finish
high school don't have a kid until you
get married get a job avoid the criminal
justice system and you will be just fine
in america
larry i know you're all into personal
responsibility but a personal curiosity
of mine is do you think we've talked
about crime in the black community all
of that sort of stuff fatherlessness etc
do you think
if there's if there's one thing the
government can and should do is to end
the war on drugs
i've never been a fan of the war on
drugs i've always felt that the that the
drugs should be should be dealt with as
a health problem and not a criminal
justice problem that said don't be this
don't be misled into believing that it
is because of the war on drugs that so
many black people are behind bars maybe
15 or so of those behind bars federal
and state are there for drug related
defenses and most of those are often
pled down from a more violent offense so
most people are in prison because
they've hurt other people but i agree
with you uh i've never believed in the
war on drugs and the war on drugs was
begun as a way to get to get it black
people uh it was perceived that a lot of
young
jazz musicians were smoking marijuana
and were enticing white women into
having sex with them and so politicians
went crazy in the 30s in these laws to
get black people so they have a racist
beginning
and they're having a disproportionately
racial effect uh on black people so i
i'm with you i think the war on drugs
should be rethought well and i'd agree
when i take your point further you talk
about most of the people are pleading
down but the violence is still happening
because they're fighting over drugs
quite often right so i i just it just
seems to me like such an obvious
solution do you have any insight as to
why
that isn't something that anyone even as
america
is ahead of us in terms of
decriminalizing say marijuana for
example
but
there doesn't seem to be any
conversation about ending the war on
drugs do you have any thoughts on why
that is i just think most americans
think that if you end the war on drugs
teenagers will start using very very
hard drugs and that the
the consequences of uh of ending the war
on drugs would be worse the consequences
of keeping it that's i think how most
people feel milton friedman the great
nobel laureate uh probably 50 years ago
argued against the war on drugs and
talked about the corrupting influence of
our criminal justice system that you
have to use snitches often uh in order
to bust people because most people
involved in drugs or both sides of the
transaction are breaking the law so you
have to use snitches in order to rat out
other people and it corrupts the entire
criminal justice system so for all those
reasons we ought to be having this
conversation but i think it's just it's
just a
a bridge too far for a lot of americans
and do you think that's going to change
particularly during the time of covid
where
a lot of institutions are struggling for
money a lot of you know a lot of local
authorities are struggling for money do
you think people are going to see it as
a way to raise tax revenue and they're
going to get in the back door that way
i suspect so same as marijuana that was
a long gradual process uh and uh as the
baby boomers are getting older and older
uh and i think the realization or the
feeling that that drugs the
the downside in prosecuting the war on
drugs uh is greater than the upside uh
in in keeping it the way it is
i didn't say that right i think that
down the road little by little uh the
war on drugs is going to be rethought
and eventually i think we're going to
have much more sensible policies but
it's going to take a while same as uh
marijuana took a while uh at first it
was medicinal marijuana and then it
became a small use for you and then it
became a thing where you can buy what
you wanted and so it's going to be
gradual just like that
yeah i think it's it's such an easy fix
in many ways and the fact that it's not
being considered is to me
mind-blowing but larry thank you so much
for your time it's been a pleasure
speaking with you and a great honor uh
let us ask you our final question which
is always the same what's the one thing
we're not talking about but we really
should be
um
we're not really talking about the
attack on merit
a lot of people are talking about the
rise in hate crimes against asian
americans when you're talking about rise
last year for example there were 22
people that were arrested in new york
city for committing hate crimes against
asian americans only two of them were
white most of them were people of color
but there are two
public high schools in america one is
called lowell high here in california
it's the top rated public high school in
california and then there's a top-rated
public high school in america called
thomas jefferson school of science and
technology in both cases until this year
the student bodies were 70 asian
american because both of those schools
required a merit-based examination now
they're getting rid of it because they
want the student body to be more
racially diverse this is a direct
assault on merit
against asian american kids who've been
busting their butts uh to go to these
schools
but there are two asian american
politicians who are senators macy orono
from hawaii and tammy duckworth illinois
both of them are yelling and screaming
about the rise in asian crimes hate
asian crimes and the rise is a small
number to a small number the real
assault on the asian american community
is what's going on at lowell high
and thomas jefferson high in fairfax
virginia and neither of these senators
has said word one about that
larry thank you so much for coming on
the show if people want to find you
online where is the best way to do that
um lariona.com be sure and check out uh
my movie uncle tom on amazon prime on
itunes and on uncle tom.com follow me on
twitter at larry older follow me on
instagram larry on the show
and uh by the way uncle tom is also
available on youtube where i watched it
and it genuinely is a brilliant
brilliant movie and i actually learned a
lot about the history of the republican
party the democratic party and house how
some of the narratives we now have about
that don't actually match what happened
so make sure you go and watch that movie
larry it's been an absolute genuinely
pleasure and honor for us to speak with
you thank you so much thank you very
much christian and thank you everybody
for watching we will see you very soon
with another interview like this one and
uh all our interviews and our live
streams go out at 7pm uk time take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below